hello everyone it was a very eventful
day one at the st. Louis rapid
tournament Gary Kasparov is undefeated
and well he played all three games quite
quite admirably in the first game
against Sergey Park and here he had a
better position and at one moment when
he should have played efore he went into
a deep sink and decided to go for III
and well the game kind of went into into
a draw but he plays it he plays it
extremely well and the second game
against Hikaru Nakamura with the black
pieces he was definitely better in the
opening and well if he just went for
some more aggressive ideas maybe maybe
the result will be different but after
after after day one Garry Kasparov said
that his main goal in day one was to
play good chest and not lose any games
because if he were to lose three games
on day one and he probably would have
played badly in the entire tournament
but he ended all of his his three games
in a draw and the third game against the
Dominguez was also a pretty quick draw
but the game I want to show you is the
game against Hikaru Nakamura so Nakamura
is white and Kasparov is black let's see
the game naka goes v4 until another six
back us borrow p4g six tonight to see
three and we have d5 the Greenfield
offense Bishop to g5 and thus far plays
Bishop to g7 and here in Nakamura plays
a sneaky variation he plays Bishop
captures and f6 Bishop captures and s6
and now seek after 75 kind of winning a
pawn here so cuz power plays c6 we have
E 4 and the power of castles we have
Knight to f3 not the spiral captures
back seek after sandy 5 and naka doesn't
capture the pawn of course he plays d5
now kicking the Bishop Bishop to g7 and
now Queen to d2 and cus power plays
Knight to c6
we have Bishop to b5 and the Bishop to
g4 by Kasparov and well this Knight is
attacked or what kind of wants the
castle and that's not really going to
happen because if he castles then simply
Bishop captures knight on f3
and the moving the Queen one more move
just to protect the night isn't
something Nakamura once so he decides to
play nice back that you want to prepare
to go to e2 and not the far place f6 and
black is better here the White King is
still in the centrist and Kasparov is
threatening to open up the position we
have h3 by Nakamura Bishop to a6 and now
he captures on f6 and the Kasparov
recaptures with the rook rook captures
on f6 and sets up a trap and if Nakamura
would try to play something like Knight
to f3 here then this would be well
instantly losing it's nice to have three
then simply rook captures on f3 and
after G captures a nice reason nice
capture son b4 now threatening to
capture this f3 pawn with a fork under
king and queen also threatening as
nicely - if the Queen moves to 2 square
and what also adding pressure to this
bishop on b5 so after rook the s6
nakamura of course saw this and he
played the Bishop captures on c6 we have
Bishop big captures on c6 and now Knight
G to E - and it's Nakamura were to play
Knight to f3 in this position because
Farah was again capture this night with
the rook rook captures on s3 and s3 G
captures on f3 this is a pretty bad
position for white as he can't really go
inside walk because it's pretty much
broken this Bishop is ready to capture
an h3 and there's really no point in
going Queen side this strong Bishop is
on g7 rook is ready to go to be 8 so
Nakamura of course so this is well so
after be captures on c6 Nakamura played
nice to eat - now preparing to castle
and cus power instantly plays Queen to
d6 activate activating the Queen
nakamura castle and we have rook a to f8
now doubling up on the F file and this
is a this is a beautiful position for
black it's smooth 16 and both life is
better
nakamura place worked 81 and here cos
para went into 2 minutes
pink and he played Bishop to c8 which is
the strongest move recommended by the
engines it prepares 'if I've and d5 is a
very important move because well
nakamura wants to play nine a4 to c5
and after E 5 this would compromise the
nice position on c5 and also there is a
threat of Bishop to e6 spinning this
night and also attacking this rook on f1
so Nakamura plays Knight to it
Knight to a4 and the Poirot plays d5
immediately so nakamura captures d
casters on e5 twin captures any five and
now nakamura plays be for creating once
more and outpost on c5 for the night and
well this is a very useful move it as it
kind of prevents Bishop to a6
immediately so we have a rook to e6 back
this bar and Nakamura place
nice to see five and okay the knife
counter the bishop through the rook
can't really go to f6 because if this
night stays on c5 and bit a6 is never a
possibility because this night would be
eyeing this d7 square so casbah plays
rook to e8 we have Knight to b3 and
Queen to be 2 and in this position
actually because power went into really
deep think he it was it was I think it
was a 10 minute sink and this is a lot
of time to spend for a rapid game but
you couldn't find any any serious
continuation for black here the engine
does give Queen to d6 but also Queens is
between 2 B 2 is also a most suggested
by the engine so pretty much because
power plays it's okay so Queen to be to
queen capture some b2 and Bishop care
for some v2 and this is a this is a good
decision because well as you can see
it's an open board and Kasparov has the
two bishops against two nights so not a
bit not a bad thing we have nice e2d for
by Nakamura and Kasparov exchanges one
sort of rooks rook captures anyone rook
captures anyone and Bishop to d7 now
defending this pawn we have rook to e to
Bishop the c3 and rook to c2 because
power capture some v4 and like a moral
casters on c6 now attacking this Bishop
here and before and also the pawn on a
seven but as far doesn't go to protect
the pawn to plays Bishop to d6 it gives
up a pawn because he does have the
bishop pair and this is this coming
compensation in a sense he does have
this best central bond we have rook to
e8 g 4 by nakamura h5 f3
rook to e1 check Kings to g2 King to f7
improving the position Knight to c6
we have h4 now and before the stage for
a move Kasparov was under a minute on
the clock here and every move can spiral
place now is in blitz or bullet mode so
he goes h4 nice C to D for we have
corrupt to d1 Nakamura offers to
exchange rooks recapture some d29
captors and d2 and the King to f6 King
to f2 and knocking 35 and if you look at
this position well what is up a pawn but
having the two bishops should be
compensation enough King 3:3 Kaspar
plays g5 and here Nakamura finds the
tricky move he plays f4 sacrificing upon
temporarily to exchange one of Gaspar
bishops we have G captures on f4 with
checked King to d3 and now because power
of place Bishop to e7 with him Knight to
f3 check King 36 and now nice the nice 5
check for king the king and Bishop and
what Kasparov has to decide which Bishop
to give up so he plays this big 27
captures an f5 we have G captures on f5
and King to c5 and now this is a very
dangerous past a pawn for Nakamura so
Kasparov has to has to be careful
we have night to d4 King to d6 a for
Bishop to d8 stopping this sponsors
going to a five nights to e6 attacking
the bishop and well this Bishop had to
go here to stop 25 but now but now
Knights to e6
attack the bishop and this pawn on f4 as
well and the point cannot be defended so
we have Bishop to b6 and nice captures
on f4 and Nakamura is up born again so
we have King to e5 Nakamura place the
strongest move he plays f6
we have a bishop
see five and now f7 well I think this
point has to be stopped by replace king
- s6 and our Knight captures on d5 woods
checks keen captures on f7 and Nakamura
plays in three four and this is probably
where Nakamura went wrong as this
disposition was winning but the idea to
win was actually to go and help this a
pawn promote but Nakamura went King side
so King to e6 Knight to f4 checks came
to d6 we have night to g3 attacking the
pawn bishop to f2 and well Nakamura will
win this pawn it's impossible to defend
that one the King gets closer King to f2
I will have Bishop to d3 King to G for a
king to c5 and now Knight captures so
the bishop has to move to s - we have a
nice to f5 king - before it's very
important to pick up this passed pawn we
have an idea g3 and up as part of
captures and what doesn't really matter
what white plays here this is it's
impossible to win this position because
this is why Nakamoto should have went
Queen side instead of king side because
here the promotion Square is a dark
square and Kasparov has a dark squared
bishop and if he were if you went the
Queen side then the pond will be
threatening to promote on a light Square
and this would be this would be okay for
I mean unstoppable for white so h4 by
Nakamura King b5 h5 Bishop 3394 King to
c6 Knight to g5 King 37 h6 King to e7 h
7 and a bishop to d4 and there is no way
for this pawn ever to promote but
Nakamura Nakamura gives it a couple of
tries you know maybe maybe he will be
able to trick us part of us he was under
a minute for the last 30 moves we have
King to f5 Bishop to a-1 King to g6 and
Bishop to b2 night to f7 with a one
night to h6 and now Bishop to HH this is
a very important move Knight to g4 and
Bishop back to a 193 vision back to h8
nice
15:36 Knight to f4 King to e7 Knight to
h3 King to e6 Knight to g5 Kings to e7
and as long as the cabarrus King
protects f7 this Bishop protects g7
there's no way for for white to break
through and well it's exactly what
happens we have Knight to f7 v to a-1
and in this position well Nakamura was
seemed very angry and he went into a
think of about three minutes and here is
where Nakamura actually plays an illegal
move he plays he plays a h8 queen but he
didn't push the pawn on h8 and then drop
Queen on h8 he just you know played it
like he was playing in a park or a bar
he just picked up the Queen and placed
it on h8 and then removed the pawn which
is considered to be an illegal move and
this would be losing the game if it was
a blitz game I'm not sure if the same
rule applies for a rapid game but even
if it doesn't I'm sure casparo wouldn't
have to call the arbiter for this so
anyway one two h8 Queen and Bishop
captures and a chase and nakamura was
already ready to capture the bishop but
as part of you know shook his hand and
they agreed to drop so yeah a fantastic
first day by garry kasparov and he is
still undefeated after day 1 so we'll
see how they 2 goes but he said that
this was a well it is very much for his
confidence as he drew against Sergey
Karjakin who was the 2016 rapid champion
and also the world championship
candidate and what he drew a rapid game
against the bullet demon himself and
what against the Dominguez as well who
isn't
who is a pretty strong player too and an
active one as well so yeah definitely
definitely a good showing by Gary
Kasparov that's it I do hope you enjoyed
it and as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here well thank you for
watching and I'll see you soon hopefully
today